this is a grass that represents the
economic history of human civilization
there's not much going on is there for
the vast majority of human history
pretty much everyone lived on the
equivalent of one dollar per day and not
much changed but then something
extraordinary happened the scientific
and industrial revolutions and the
basically flat graph you just saw
transforms into this what this graph
means is that in terms of power to
change the world
we live an unprecedented time in human
history and I believe our ethical
understanding hasn't yet caught up with
this fact the scientific and industrial
revolutions transformed both our
understanding of the world and our
ability to alter it what we need is an
ethical revolution so that we can work
out how do we use this tremendous bounty
of resources to improve the world for
the last 10 years my colleagues and I
have developed a philosophy and research
program that we call effective altruism
it tries to respond to these radical
changes in our world uses evidence and
careful reasoning to try to answer this
question how can we do the most good now
there are many issues you've got to
address if you want to tackle this
problem whether to do good through your
charity or your career or your political
engagement or programs to focus on who
to work with but what I want to talk
about is what I think is the most
fundamental problem of all the many
problems that the world faces which
should we be focused on finest all first
now I'm going to give you a framework
for thinking about this question and the
framework is very simple a problems
higher priority the bigger
the more easily solvable and the more
neglected it is bigger this better
because we've got more to gain if we do
solve a problem more easily solvable is
better because I can solve the problem
with less time or money and most subtly
more neglected is better because of
diminishing of a turns the more these
horses they've already been invested
into solving a problem the harder it
will be to make additional progress now
the key thing that I want to leave with
you is this framework so that you can
think for yourself what are the highest
global priorities but I and others in
the effective Alton community have
converged on three moral issues that we
believe are unusually important score
unusually well on this framework first
is global health this is super solvable
we have an amazing track record in
global health
rates of death from measles malaria
diarrheal disease are down by over 70%
and in 1980 we eradicated smallpox is
tomato thereby saved over 60 million
lives that's more alive saved than if
we'd achieved world peace in that same
time period on our current best
estimates we can save a life by
distributing long-lasting insecticide
treated bed nets for just a few thousand
dollars this is an amazing opportunity
the second big priority is factory
farming this is super neglected there
are fifty billion land animals used
every year for food and the vast
majority of them effectively farmed
living in conditions of horrific
suffering they're probably among the
worst off creatures in this planet and
in many cases we could significantly
improve their lives for just pennies per
animal yet this is hugely neglected
there are three thousand times more
animals and factory farms than there are
stray pets but yet factory farming kits
one fiftieth of the philanthropic
funding
that means that additional resources in
this area can have a truly
transformative impact now the third area
is the one that I want to focus on the
most and that's the category of
existential risks events like a nuclear
war or the global pandemic that could
permanently derail civilization or even
leads to the extinction of the human
race let me explain why I think this is
such a big priority in terms of this
framework first size how bad would it be
if there were a truly existential
catastrophe well it would involve the
deaths of all seven billion people on
this planet and that means you and
everyone you know and love that's the
Society of unimaginable science but then
what's more it would also mean the
curtailment of humanity's future
potential and I believe that for
humanity's potential is vast the human
race has been around for about 200,000
years and if she lives as long as a
typical mammalian species she would last
for about two million years if the human
race were a single individual she would
be just ten years old today and what's
more the human race isn't a typical
mammalian species there's no reason why
if we're careful we should die off after
only two million years the earth will
remain habitable for 500 million years
to come and if someday we took to the
stars the civilization could continue
for billions more so I think the future
is going to be really big but is it
gonna be good it's the is the human race
even really worth preserving
well we hear all the time about how
things have been getting worse I think
that when we take the long run things
have been getting radically better here
for example is life expectancy over time
here is the proportion of people not
living in actually in poverty
here's the number of countries over time
that
decriminalized homosexuality here's a
number of countries over time they've
become democratic then when we look to
the future there could be so much more
to gain again will be so much richer we
can solve so many problems that are
intractable today so if this is kind of
a graph of how humanity is progressed in
terms of total human flourishing over
time well this is what we would expect
future progress to look like its vast
here for example is where we'd expect
no-one to live in extreme poverty here
is where we would expect everyone to be
better off than the richest person alive
today perhaps here is where we discover
the fundamental natural laws that govern
our world perhaps here as we discover an
entirely new form of art a form of music
that we currently lack the ears to hear
and this is just the next few thousand
years
once we think past that well we can't
even imagine the heights that human
accomplishment might reach so the
futures could be really big and it could
be really good but are there ways we
could lose this value and sadly I think
there are the last two centuries but
some end as technological progress but
they also brought the global risks to
nuclear war and the possibility of
extreme climate change when we look to
the coming centuries we should expect to
see the same pattern again and we can
see some radically powerful technologies
on the horizon synthetic biology might
give us the power to create viruses of
unprecedented contagiousness and
lethality geoengineering might give us
the power to dramatically alter the
Earth's climate
artificial intelligence might give us
the power to create intelligent agents
with abilities greater than our own now
I'm not saying that any of these risks
are particularly likely but when there's
so much at stake even small
probabilities matter of a great deal
imagine if you're getting on a plane and
you kind of nervous and the pilot
reassures you by saying there's only one
in a thousand chance of crashing don't
worry
would you feel reassured for these
reasons I think the deserving the future
of humanity is among the most important
problems that we currently face but
let's keep using this framework is this
problem neglected and I think the answer
is yes and that's because problems that
affect future generations are often
hugely neglected
why because future people don't
participate in markets today they don't
have a vote it's not like there's a
lobby about presenting the interests of
those born in 2300 ad they don't get
influenced the decisions we make today
they're voiceless and that means we
still spend a paltry amount on these
issues nuclear non-proliferation
geoengineering by a risk artificial
intelligent safety all of these receive
only a few tens of millions of dollars
of philanthropic funding every year
that's tiny compared to the three
hundred and ninety billion dollars that
spent on us philanthropy in total final
aspect of our framework then is this
solvable I believe it is you can
contribute with your money your career
or your political engagement with your
money you can support organizations that
focus on these risks like the nuclear
threat initiative which campaign to take
nuclear weapons off here take an alert
or the blue lemon panel which develops
policy to minimize the damage the
natural and man-made pandemics or the
Center for human compatible AI that does
technical research to ensure the AI
systems are safe and reliable with your
political engagement you can vote for
candidates that care about these risks
and you can support greater
International Cooperation then with your
career there is so much that you can do
of course we need scientists and policy
makers and organizational leaders but
just as importantly we also need
accounts
and managers and assistants to work in
these organizations that are tackling
these problems now the research program
of effective altruism still in its
infancy and there's still a huge amount
that we don't know but even with what
we've learned so far we can see that by
thinking carefully and by focusing on
those problems that are big solvable and
neglected we can make a truly tremendous
difference to the world for thousands of
years to come thank you
[Applause]